your dad hasn't called and told you he's
proud of you now as that Call's not
coming
stop chasing for it
if your mom is somebody who critiques
every second of your life it's not going
to stop no matter how much money you
make how big things get and I talk to
Business Leaders and they call me out on
this or you telling me not to be
ambitious you tell me not to have a big
business no
I see this state of the world I've got
two little kids involved in this I need
you to go do great things powerful big
things huge things
please
but I also need you to know it's
not going to heal you
and if you will do the work to be well
it will make this other stuff infinitely
more scalable